hey this is really interesting news out
of texas
uh actor matthew mcconaughey or
mcconaughey as some people like to say
is polling 12 points ahead of republican
texas governor greg abbott
he's not running if your reaction was i
didn't know that
he was running he's not uh this is a new
poll from the dallas morning
news and the university of texas tyler
it's based on 1100 registered voters
30 percent democrats 37 percent
republicans
33 percent who are neither 45 percent of
voters
say they would support matthew
mcconaughey over greg
abbott if matthew mcconaughey were to
run for governor
33 said they'd support abbott over
mcconaughey
22 say they would vote for someone else
or aren't really sure
this is interesting because mcconaughey
has actually kind of teased and alluded
to maybe running
in the state of texas he is not
confirmed
he told cnbc last month he is not joking
he said quote i'm not
teasing the idea i'm actually looking at
the idea and giving it serious
consideration
i have a new chapter for myself
personally in my life i believe it's
some sort of leadership role i don't
know what the role is i don't know my
category
we've been talking about the why of
leadership and even
i would say we need some more good
leaders
this would be fascinating so
there's two parts to this i don't know
how much this says about matthew
mcconaughey specifically
uh what i mean by that is greg abbott
has so mismanaged almost everything i
mean the pandemic
the power outage and grid electrical
grid situation
he's a complete and total clown who
doesn't seem to care much about the
health or safety or welfare of people in
texas
it's possible a random school teacher
with no name recognition
would maybe do okay against greg abbott
so part of it is we have to figure out
how much of it is
matthew mcconaughey specifically uh but
then you add in the fact that
if you look at matthew mcconaughey over
the last 12 to 18 months i've been
seeing him doing more and more
conversations and interviews
with people in the political space he
does actually seem interested he seems
to be taking this seriously i don't know
the guy's politics i have no idea
whether
uh he's a democrat or a republican i
don't know anything about him what i do
know though
is that he at least doesn't seem like a
radical right winger if he is a
centrist or further left and if without
even announcing a candidacy he is doing
this well in texas
what we saw in 2020 in texas the
tightening in texas for trump
uh in in his re-election campaign uh
which ultimately didn't end up being
that close but it was
could it could have been a much much
bigger uh margin for donald trump
this could signal significant changes in
the state of texas
and uh we are all we can do is continue
to follow it we've been talking about it
before
georgia and texas have been the ones
that we've been watching relatively
closely
very interesting and we're going to keep
a close eye on that